hey how's it going bros my name is Gary
simulator it got updated there's some
cool new oh my god
alright whoa
you tuned alright so there's some new
features added I wanted to check them
out together with you bros they look
really cool are there any new panties
yes underwear for old fashion girls
seriously old fashion girls extra static
points alright well that's good I
actually need that that's pretty that's
pretty nice
it's my kidnap no I have an in sanur I
didn't save I can't wait for you to like
do stuff with your kidnaps let's go to
school
so there's a fountain here now wow so
nice I love phantoms he never knows how
much I love him I love him so much
who's through the hell is that [ __ ] why
is she walking behind sampai who the
hell hey excuse me
hi they just say you look like an anime
girl
that's so nice of you to say so what our
plan for this episode is to make someone
fall off this roof
oh yeah there's bathrooms now which I
think you can use I'm not sure how well
see if someone goes in there now you
have a mazing side boobs make a Chan so
does the other girl a real laughing and
having fun they're all having fun right
so much fun
broy so anyway about that tampon how do
I get it out what is he doing here
are you some sent by what are you what
is he doing all at home I he's such a
broken spirit but I'd really Easter Egg
menu okay real check this out slender
mode hahahahaha punished mode of snake
nice
I love titties
we have been sure mode I'm sure this is
an anime reference that I don't know
about Titan mode I know as well gala
mode alpha fun see Donkey Kong mode and
finally for the Oh
hitman mode which kind of makes sense
actually well they're having fun while
they're making this game or what people
are going to the roof okay okay this is
what we wanted alright so here
apparently you can eavesdrop on people
if they don't see you and I obviously
have amazing cigar do search on panties
I mean sneaking skills and make a
challenge oh my god well it's nothing if
you don't talk about it that's fine
ever since my mom died my dad's been
drinking a lot
sometimes when he's drunk he comes into
my room and oh [ __ ] okay that's bad news
right okay so now we have some intel on
this lady who I obviously hate for many
many reasons
oh [ __ ] I'm late for class [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] where's the [ __ ] is
class when you're late for class ah
which one is her locker okay let's leave
a note I want to talk about domestic
abuse please meet me at their rooftop at
4:00 p.m.
BAM uh I wasn't made I was just slurping
about you what's this I should meet them
I can almost see make a chance panties
[ __ ] is gonna pay for walking near Sam
pies presents 4 p.m. where the [ __ ] is
she on a son of a [ __ ]
where is she there's yes no one can see
me I am the danger
all right justice whoopsie oh my god no
she committed suicide
Oh No how unfortunate better get out of
here I wanna I hope she's alive seconds
how I like to deliver a sick line to her
it appears the student has committed
suicide
the police concluded that the student
and in her own life what a great start
of the week fantastic
alright first I'm gonna turn that
episode there this game is so awesome I
can't wait to play more wants to get
updated bros for you enjoyed this video
now's a great time to leave a like and
i'll see you in the next one as always
stay awesome bros bigger check this yeah
say go hey look at my rap it's over 12
maybe you should let that guy through
she's like back off make this one is
mine